MALE SPEAKER 1: --ing
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
JEFF POSNICK: And this week
we're actually coming from the
main studio in New York.
And I'm Jeff Posnick from the
YouTube Developer Relations
Team out here in New York.
And for a change, we have Jarek
and Jeremy joining us
from Mountain View in kind
of a remote location.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello.
JEFF POSNICK: Hey, guys.
Good morning, guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hey, Jeff.
How are you doing?
JEFF POSNICK: I'm doing
well, thanks.
I'm--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Live from
New York, but it's not
Saturday yet.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
It's the fun Wednesday
afternoon broadcast
scene in New York.
And yeah, how I'm doing is, for
those of you who have been
following along religiously to
our YouTube Developer Lives,
you've probably been able to
track the progress of my cold.
And from about a month and a
half ago, I was completely out
of commission and couldn't make
broadcast, to as I've
slowly been coming back and just
providing some background
of coughing and things
like that.
So you can expect the coughing
to be in the
foreground this week.
I have my hot tea ready.
Nice sponsorship with the
generic Moening cup company.
So bear with me, please, if
I'm coughing at any point.
But the reason we're going live
from New York in this
particular case is that we
wanted to devote this week's
session to YouTube
Direct Lite.
And YouTube Direct Lite is a
project that is very near and
dear to my heart.
It is something I've been
working on for a number of
months now.
And it's kind of the evolution
of the whole
YouTube Direct platform.
And for those of you who might
not be familiar with YouTube
Direct or YouTube Direct Lite, I
want to start by just giving
you some background and talk
about why you might want to
use YouTube Direct or YouTube
Direct Lite in particular.
So let's say that you are
somebody who's running a
website, and you want to have
a way of soliciting feedback
from users of your website.
And there's obviously ways of
doing that via text comments
or things along those lines.
But we're YouTube.
We think things should be doable
via video and easy to
do via video.
And we'd like to make it easier
for folks to solicit
video feedback from
their users.
And this could be any type
of video playback.
It could be people sending in
from a web cam and answering a
question that a news
organization asks about.
It could be people have captured
kind of like citizen
journalism or citizen
reporting,
submitting to a site.
It could be a gaming website
that might have members of a
certain online guild upload
videos of their playback
experience or something
along those lines.
A whole host of possible
solutions.
And the problem is that while
there are definitely ways of
doing that using the YouTube
API, a lot of that requires a
good deal of programming.
And not all people who are
hosting their own websites are
developers.
And it's also not a great idea
to ask people to start coding
the same thing over and
over and over again.
So providing a platform that
takes care of all those common
activities that normally involve
the soliciting of
video uploads, and then also
featuring the video uploads
that have been moderated by
the website owner and
approved, that's something that
we wanted to accomplish
with YouTube Direct and now
with YouTube Direct Lite.
One of the important things to
note is that this follows our
best practices for uploads.
And those of you who have
tuned into some of our
previous shows, I think it was
a couple weeks ago you heard
me talk for about 30 minutes
about best practices for
soliciting uploads and making
sure that you don't have the
uploads all go into one
master account.
The idea is that users should
first authenticate against
their own YouTube accounts.
And then you can use
the API to upload
videos into that account.
And that's what YouTube
Direct Lite does.
So you have an easy
way of doing that.
It all uses OAuth2, which
is our standard
authorization method.
And I'll walk you through the
flow in a little bit.
One of the--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I have a
question for you before you
get too much into the
YouTube Direct.
I'm a little bit of a
tech history buff.
I love the Computer History
Museum here in Mountain View.
And I'm always curious,
how do projects start?
So how did your project start?
Was your wife involved
in any way?
There's all these tech companies
that get started
because of wives.
Like what prompted
you to actually
start working on this?
JEFF POSNICK: Now I'm
really suspicious.
Was my wife involved
in any way?
Not as far as I know.
I mean, YouTube Direct came
about probably about three
years ago now.
And that was kind of the whole
genesis of the project.
And it was actually one of the
first things I worked on when
I joined the YouTube API team.
And we were thinking a lot about
citizen journalism, in
that particular case and trying
to help folks collect
news stories.
But it's always been more than
just the whole citizen
journalism use case.
We want to make this kind
of a generic way
of soliciting videos.
And then YouTube Direct Lite
came about more recently.
And what actually prompted me
to write it is the fact that
we can now do something that's
purely client-side JavaScript
that has most of the same
functionality as YouTube Direct.
And I'm going to talk about
that a little bit later.
But because YouTube Direct
Lite is pure client-side
JavaScript--
and notice I'm wearing my HTML5
T-shirt today instead of
my normal YouTube developer
T-shirt because I wanted to
give HTML5 some love, and
particularly cross-origin
resource sharing, which is the
part of the HTML5 spec that
really powers a lot of what
YouTube Direct Lite can do.
For the first time recently,
we were able to write
something that did not require
server-side deployment but had
most of the same functionality
as what our older YouTube
Direct project had.
So I will have to defer to
my wife whether she had
any input or not.
But as far as I recall, that's
kind of the background story.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So you are becoming more
of a client-side
guy over the years?
You started off in the
cloud, and now it's
all about the browser?
JEFF POSNICK: I wouldn't
say that it's
all about the browser.
And I certainly am very well
aware of some of the
limitations that the pure
client-side solution has.
I mean, you'll notice we're not
calling it YouTube Direct
2.0 or 3.0 or anything
like that.
We're calling it Lite because
there are certain things that
we just can't do yet in
client-side code.
But what we really wanted to do
was provide something that
was as easy as possible for
folks who want to use YouTube
Direct and perhaps in the past
have wanted to use YouTube
Direct but were really just
not able to overcome the
technical barrier of having to
check out source code, open up
Eclipse, deploy their own Java
App Engine instance, all those
things that were required
in the earlier projects.
So doing browser-based code that
we could host ourselves,
host for them on their behalf,
really made this possible.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So are you going to give us a
demo, or what's the plan?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
Just one other thing I want to
mention before giving the demo
of what this looks like is the
fact that this is kind of our
flagship usage of the YouTube
upload widget.
So for those who have seen
this year's Google I/O
presentation that we gave, we
did a joint presentation on
the upload widget and
YouTube Direct Lite.
And what the upload widget
allows is, for the first time,
the ability to just drop in some
code onto any existing
web page-- and YouTube Direct
Lite is just a web page--
and to allow you to solicit web
cam uploads from any of
your users.
And those web cam uploads
go directly into
the user's own account.
And this doesn't require any
deployment on your side.
Previously, you kind of have
to run your own Flash Media
server yourself if you wanted
to do this sort of thing.
But we're pointing this widget
at our own infrastructure.
So this is a great way to make
use of the upload widget if
you use it as part of
YouTube Direct Lite.
But it's also kind of a
standalone project and a
standalone widget that you could
put into any web page.
So we'll show what that upload
widget looks like
a little bit later.
But I definitely wanted to point
out that that's some new
functionality that's
there that we're
pretty excited about.
So I think we're going to switch
to the demo right now.
And I'll walk through a little
bit of what you could do.
And there's two aspects to
YouTube Direct Lite.
And that's the submission
interface.
And then there is a moderation
So I'm going to first show you
what the submission interface
looks like.
And the important thing to
point out is that this is
something that you can
just put on to any
existing web page.
So if you take a look at--
I'm just going to quickly
pull up the source
code for this page.
There's really nothing
complicated here.
It's just a very simple
web page.
There's a little bit of the
iFrame embed over here for the
actual YouTube Direct
upload widget.
There's another iFrame over here
for the playlist player.
And honestly, both of the pages,
have the JavaScript
that's needed for Google
Analytics, honestly.
So it's very straightforward
to add this to any page.
And the interface is what
you see down here.
So you get this little iFrame.
You could customize the
size obviously, and
that sort of thing.
And you are taken initially,
when you click on Login, to
the OAuth2 login flow for
web-based applications.
And this is really important.
For those of you who have been
following along to all of our
developer communications pretty
much universally for
the past two years or so, you've
heard about how OAuth2
is the future.
And OAuth2 is the recommended
means of doing authorization
moving forward.
So this is making
use of OAuth2.
You'll see YouTube Direct Lite
is requesting permission to
manage your YouTube accounts.
I happen to already
be signed in.
So it's not going to ask me to
sign into my Google slash
YouTube account again.
But if I were not already signed
in in this instance, I
could have first signed in.
But I see exactly what
the application is.
I see what it's trying to do.
And I can now click
Allow Access.
I don't have to give
the application my
username or my password.
So it's just a nice way that the
OAuth2 kind of abstracts
that away and means that you
don't have to give your
credentials to third-party
applications anymore.
So I'm going to click
Allow Access.
And I should be redirected back
to this page, as I am.
And I am now taken to this
interface where I
can submit my video.
So this is kind of default user
interface for YouTube
Direct Lite that you're
seeing right here.
And let me make it a little
bigger for the benefit of
those following along.
So this is obviously
a little generic.
And one of the things that you
can do with YouTube Direct
Lite is check out the
code yourself.
This is a fully open
source project.
And if you want YouTube Direct
Lite to match the way that
your website looks-- you know,
specific color theme, or if
you want to customize any of the
options, if you want to do
things like change some of the
text around, you have the
ability to do that by basically
just forking the
code yourself.
And it's hosted from gets,
a GET repository on
code.google.com.
So it's really easy to push a
copy of the code down to your
client and then make the
changes that you want.
But this is what the default
interface looks like.
And this is the interface that
you'll get if, instead of
making a local copy of the code,
you just point to the
iFrame source that
we host for you.
So it's kind of just a benefit
we're doing to make things
super, super easy for folks
who don't want customize
anything, for folks
who just want the
ability to solicit videos.
All you need to do is add an
iFrame with the correct source
to any existing web page.
I'll talk you through the steps
for doing that in a
little bit after I go
through the demo.
So I don't have a local video
to upload from my hard drive
as part of this demo.
But if I did, I could
choose the file over
here and click Upload.
What I can do is either submit
a video that's already
existing in my YouTube
accounts.
So I have a couple of general
videos right over here.
You get to see Jarek's head
in the background
for that demo video.
If I don't remember what these
videos are, I could pick Play
over here, and quickly just see
an inline preview of what
the video is using our standard
YouTube player.
And this is actually
really nice.
If nothing else, I recommend
folks who are trying to do
something similar to take
a look at our code.
And you can feel free to steal
that portion that converts
from a standard--
you see over here,
this is just a
standard image right now.
And then we have a special on
click handler setup that will
initialize the iFrame player
when you click on it rather
than having to initialize
multiple instances of the
iFrame player ahead of time.
So feel free to steal that
code if you think
that would be useful.
And then we have this
web cam interface.
And this is making use of the
upload widget that I talked
about before.
So clicking on Record over
there brings this up.
And I hopefully will not get
an unresponsive instance of
Chrome in this case.
It looks like it's not happy.
Something Flash related is
not happy, unfortunately.
So I cannot show that particular
demo right now.
And I'll show instead just
submitting one of these
existing videos.
So click up here on Submit
Video, and my video submission
was received.
So that's one end of things.
That is submitting, and that's
what your users will see.
But the whole idea is that these
videos are not in any
particular YouTube account.
These videos all live in the
YouTube accounts that belong
to the people who actually
submitted the videos.
So there's really no way of
knowing about these videos
unless you have some
identification that gets
attached to them as part
of the submission.
So we're actually making
use of keywords
within those videos.
And we are using that to kind
of find all the submissions
that come in and present that
to a Moderator in this
administrator interface that
you're looking at right now.
So actually, let me walk
through the full steps.
So this is what happens when you
want to moderate a YouTube
Direct Lite instance.
You first select a playlist.
YouTube Direct Lite is organized
around the concept
of the playlist.
So whenever you have a
submission widget on the page,
that submission widget
is associated
with a specific playlist.
And here I just have a few
different tests over here.
I believe the one that I've
been using to solicit
submissions on that page is
this YouTube Direct Lite
Submissions playlist.
You could also just
create a brand new
playlist if you'd like.
And this is all making use of
the standard YouTube API calls
for creating playlist and
fetching playlist information.
And it's all done client side
using the cross-origin
resource sharing capability
that's in many major browsers.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hey, Jeff.
This is Jarek.
I have a question
about this part.
So when you started the demo,
there was an OAuth flow, and
that was authorizing the
application to act on behalf
of the user that was submitting
the video, right?
So the videos go into
somebody's account.
Now playlist management
also requires
authorized access, right?
So how does the OAuth flow
work for this part?
Like how do you actually
configure the playlist?
Because this is not the playlist
of the user, right?
This is the playlist of
the administrator.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So if I had been really fancy, I
would have found a way to do
like two different Chrome
incognito windows signed into
different accounts, so I could
show a demo of Account A is
the person submitting a video,
and Account B is the person
who manages the playlist.
So this is a little bit
of a contrived demo.
And the person submitting the
video and the person managing
the playlist is the
same account.
And since I'm already signed
in to that account and I've
already gone through the OAuth2
flow once, I don't have
to go through it again
at this step.
Normally, if I am an
administrator, and I haven't
previously submitted a video
from the same browser session
right before, I would have to
go through the OAuth2 flow
once and authorize
access before I
could get to this page.
So definitely a great
question.
But it is using the same sort
of OAuth2 protection as the
other page that you
just saw was.
One of the nice things about
OAuth2 is that you do not have
to continuously re-log in.
So this will actually remember
the first time that I allow
access to my specific accounts
to this specific application.
And subsequent times when I go
to the page, I'll just already
automatically be logged in.
And we do have the Log
Out link for those
who want to log out.
But it just makes it a lot
easier to use in this
particular case rather than have
to remember to type in
your password and click Allow
each time you go to a page.
Going back to the administrator
interface, let's
say that you are going to have
this playlist, and you want to
start soliciting submissions for
videos that'll end up in
that playlist.
Clicking on that playlist will
take you to this Embed Codes
tab over here.
And what you get right here is
the exact iFrame code that you
need to insert it into any
page, and ensure that the
submissions made on that
page are associated
with that given playlist.
This again does not mean that
the videos will automatically
appear in a playlist
as soon as they're
submitted by the user.
You still have to review them in
this Pending tab over here.
But that's just one way of
saying if the video is
approved, this is the playlist
that it should go into.
And it should appear into the
Pending tab over here when I'm
looking at things in
that playlist.
So you can imagine you might be
a website that's running 10
different submission forms
on 10 different pages for
different topics.
You'd separate them all into
distinct playlists and kind of
segregate the work based on that
and feature the videos
separately also based on that.
Because the other thing that's
available on this page is this
iFrame embed code that will
allow you to put the standard
YouTube playlist player
onto any web page.
And that playlist player will
automatically show all the
featured videos for
a given playlist.
So that's what we have right
over here for instance.
Let me see.
On this page we have a
submission over here.
And that just corresponds to
this type of playlist code.
And again, it has the playlist
ID already filled in for you
so you don't have to look that
up or anything like that.
For folks who don't want to
continually go back to the
Pending tab and check for new
submissions, we also have a
link to an RSS feed that will
automatically be updated any
time there's a new submission
that comes
into to a given playlist.
So that's another really useful
feature that you could
use to keep track of what's
being submitted.
So I'm actually thinking that
the playlist I submitted the
video to might be slightly
different than this one.
Yeah.
So I might not be able to find
the exact playlist over here.
And maybe over here is one.
Here we go.
OK.
So this just gives
you a demo of--
I'm just using a slightly
different playlist.
But it gives you an idea
of what the admin
interface looks like.
So there's no pending videos
in this particular case.
But I have three videos that
I previously approved.
They had been submitted.
I could play them back
again in here.
If I realize, hey, I don't
actually want this video
approved, I could
click on Reject.
See?
It disappears, a nice little--
I think that is--
I don't even think
that's jQuery UI.
I think that's just standard
jQuery and some animation with
the CSS effects to get it to
disappear into that rejected
tab over there.
JEREMY: Hey, Jeff.
I have a quick question.
JEFF POSNICK:
JEREMY: So you're pulling these
videos into the approved
list by a specialized keyword
that associates it with the
playlist, right?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
JEREMY: So when you're rejecting
them, I'm guessing
because you're now signed in
only as the admin with OAuth2,
you can't obviously remove
that keyword, right?
So how are you moving it from
pending to rejected?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I'm cheating a little bit.
So the way I do that is by
creating a new playlist in the
administrator's accounts that
I think has a name, YTDL
Rejected Videos.
And every time you reject a
video, that video gets added
to that rejected videos
playlist.
And this is a private playlist,
so it's not really
visible to anybody else.
You don't have to worry about
it showing up anywhere.
And I'm really just kind of
overloading the use of a
playlist in this case to act as
a kind of a glorified data
store, let's say.
And it's a way of keeping track
of all the videos that
have previously been
marked as rejected.
And it's very similar to
how we populate the
approved tab, also.
We read the video that's
currently in the given
playlist in the approved
tab, and we display
them all over here.
So for the rejected tab, we just
show all the videos that
are in that particular rejected
playlist that
happened to have been
tagged with the
playlist ID in question.
So not necessarily the
most let's say--
I don't know.
I don't know what derogatory
term I should use.
JEREMY: No, no, it's
interesting.
JEFF POSNICK: It's not the thing
I'm most proud of in the
world, but it was one way of
working around the fact that
we don't have any real
server-side store of data.
So we kind of opened the
link to the playlist.
JEREMY: So also the OAuth2
permission is not kept
anywhere, right?
So you don't really have the
ability to later on go back
and say, add a tag, or remove a
tag, or add a developer tag
to the video, right?
The flow is actually forgotten
as soon as the
user leaves the browser?
JEFF POSNICK: Right.
So YouTube Direct was a little
bit different in that we would
keep track of the OAuth--
or I guess in that case it
was AuthSub credentials--
for the user who submitted
the video.
And then when we approved the
video, we would have those
credentials of the
submitting user.
And we could use them to, for
instance, make an update to
the video's description, to say,
hey, this video has been
approved and added to this
playlist, or do some other
things like that.
We don't have that capability
in YouTube
Direct Lite, though.
The OAuth2 credentials are not
stored anywhere except in
whatever Google infrastructure
stores
everybody's OAuth2 approvals.
So it's not something
we have access to.
And I kind of had to think a
little bit to find a viable
work around for that use case.
So I think that gives a pretty
good, decent overview of how
you actually use YouTube
Direct Lite.
As I mentioned, you could check
out the code yourself
and deploy it to a local web
server and customize the CSS
or JavaScript or HTML, if
you want things to look
differently.
But I wanted to talk a little
bit about how we actually
built it and run through some
of the code as well.
So YouTube Direct Lite, as I
mentioned at the top, is only
possible because we added
support for Cross-Origin
Resource Sharing, or CORS,
to the YouTube data API.
And that means that we can now
make authenticated and rights.
I guess read rights that YouTube
API calls directly
from the browser
in JavaScript.
So folks are familiar with
other ways of talking to
YouTube API, like using
something like JSONP, where
you had a way of getting
read-only data by inserting a
script tag onto the page that
would end up executing a
callback function.
That all kind of works.
It's not really--
I wouldn't say it's an abuse of
HTML or anything like that.
It's a very well-established
practice.
But it's not really something
native to the browser.
It's not using native JavaScript
constructs.
It's not using an XML HTTP
request, which is what CORS
does, for instance.
So now that that's available
in the API for any browser
that supports it, and that
is most modern browsers.
It's not Internet Explorer
9, unfortunately.
I think Internet Explorer 10 is
going to have full support
for the CORS standard.
But in any supported browser
we make heavy use of that.
We're actually just
using jQuery.
JQuery is AJAX wrapper around
XML HTTP requests to do a lot
of our CORS calls.
I'll show you some of that
code a little bit later.
Lots of jQuery everywhere.
We're actually using some local
caching using the local
storage capabilities for
HTML5, using our former
colleague Pamela Fox's LSCache
JavaScript library, which has
a really nice way of expiring
data after a certain point in
time and kind of making local
storage work like memcache.
So that's been kind of cool.
And that was really
useful to use.
And I'm also using RequireJS,
which is a framework for kind
of breaking JavaScript code
into a bunch of different
modules and specify module
dependencies and refactoring
my code that was not initially
written to RequireJS to start
supporting RequireJS was a
little bit of a headache.
But it was definitely something
I should have done
from the beginning.
So I'm glad I did it.
And it kind of has resulted in
a lot cleaner code and more
modularized code.
So I highly recommend RequireJS
for folks who might
be thinking of tackling
similar projects.
And I wanted to also mention,
we're using the YouTube player
and upload widget, libraries
that I already
talked about before.
But we're kind of using the
standard interface there.
So I wanted to run through
some code before we do
anything else and pull up code
from the Google Code Project.
And I wanted to first talk
about how we're using the
upload widgets.
So this is something that might
be a little bit new to
folks because we just
announced this
a few months ago.
And you might not have seen very
much sample code of how
to use the upload widget
in a real world
setting, for instance.
So I wanted to show
that off now.
And a lot of this at the top
right over here, this is just
something that has to do
with how RequireJS--
line 17 over here-- how
RequireJS handles module
dependencies.
We're just basically saying that
this module depends on
all these other modules.
So don't worry too much
about that over here.
But I wanted to point out how
we're initializing the code
for the upload widget.
And what we're doing is actually
checking to see if
the YT upload widget namespace
is currently defined.
We don't want to keep loading
in the external JavaScript
definition for the
upload widget
interface multiple times.
We only want it to happen the
first time, if it's necessary.
So we're kind of making
use of lazy loading.
And we're making use of this
check to ensure that we only
load it once.
So if it is not already defined,
the first thing we do
is initialize this callback
over here.
This is the standard callback
that gets invoked whenever the
code for both the upload widget
and the player iFrame
API code is loaded.
And it's window on YouTube
iFrame API ready.
And you can see that we have
this callback over here that
says load upload widget.
That's our function a little
bit down over here.
And what we next do
is make use of
jQuery's get.Script method.
And this basically will just
insert a script tag into the
DOM for us with a source that
points to this URL.
One interesting thing I wanted
to mention about the URL, you
notice that there's no
HTTP or HTTPS prefix.
It's just this slash,
slash over here.
This is what I recommend
everybody start doing.
And if they don't do this, then
at very least, if you're
going to hardcode something, you
should put hardcode HTTPS
rather than HTTP.
And using the slash slash, this
is a little interesting.
This is called--
I think it's called scheme
relative addressing.
And if your host web page is
accessed via HTTP, then this
will tell the browser, hey,
it's OK to load this
resource via HTTP.
And if your host web page is
accessed via HTTPS, though,
just know, hey, I need to load
the HTTPS version of this
resource rather than
the HTTP version.
And this is really important to
avoid, like mixed-content
warnings that most modern
browsers will present to you
if a page tries--
if a page is accessed via HTTPS
initially but then tries
to later on load
via JavaScript,
something via HTTP.
So rather than having to worry
about checking to see what the
scheme of the host page is or
anything like that, just make
use of this scheme relative
addressing and thank me later.
So what we're going to do over
here is if we already have
loaded the code before, we'll
just call web cam upload,
uploaded to widget directly, and
that's the same callback
that would happen after it
gets loaded over here.
So whatever this function is
called, we know that our Y2
upload widget namespace
is available.
And the way the upload widget's
API actually works is
somewhat similar to the player
API, for those who are
familiar with that.
You initialize it by calling
the Y2 upload widget
constructor and pass in the
name of the ID of the div
element that's going to be
replaced with the actual
upload widget.
And you pass in some event
definitions over here.
And this is saying when the
upload widget is ready, I want
to set the video title to
whatever the default title is.
The description, I want to set
the keywords for the video to
this particular playlist ID.
This is kind of the whole
keyword-based searching that
we used to populate the list
of pending videos.
So I need to be sure that I'm
setting the property keywords
on the videos.
And we also have different
methods for when the upload is
complete or when there's
an error, for instance.
So we just have some ways of
displaying a little message
when the web cam submission's
successful or
when there's an error.
We're also just making use of
Google Analytics for tracking
specific events, like when web
cam submission was successful
or when there was an error.
So that's what's going
on over there.
I wanted to then pop to kind
of a quick tour through one
piece of relevant CSS that
I mentioned before.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Jeff,
before you go
there, one quick question.
So when the web cam widget
completes the video upload,
how does the application know
about the actual video?
Do you take events through
that in your code?
Or this is always basically
search based?
For example, can you get
the video ID somehow?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So sorry for not mentioning
that.
Because I'm not actually making
use of the fact that
the callback includes
the video ID.
This event object that
gets passed in to the
OnUploadSuccess is actually- you
can see, it's ignored by
my callback.
So I'm not looking at that or
making use of the fact that
the keyword is going to help
us find the video later on.
But if you're writing an
application that's using the
upload widget, and you really
just want to get notified
immediately--
actually, immedified is kind
of a useful neologism with
both of those words
put together.
If you want to get immedified
about the new video ID once
it's available, you can hook
up something in your
OnUploadSuccess handler that'll
take a look at, I
think it's event.data.videoID.
But check our Docs for
the specific syntax.
And you can, at that point, load
a YouTube player on the
page right after the upload
succeeds where the person can
then play back the video.
Or you can make use of that
video ID and store it in some
local database somewhere
or anything like that.
So there definitely is that
functionality for
those who need it.
OK, So I'm going to just quickly
pop over to something
of the CSS I mentioned
a little bit.
And this took me a little
bit of fiddling around.
For those who've played around
in CSS before, you know that
it's 90% fiddling and
changing things.
Actually, the Chrome--
I don't know.
What do we call, I guess, a
developer tools panel, is
really useful for this.
Because it lets you peek at the
specific CSS properties
running element and change
it in real time.
So instead of having to
constantly save your CSS file
and then reload the page, you
could actually go in and edit
the CSS properties and
immediately live in the DOM
see how it affects things.
So that proved very useful
for doing this.
But I just wanted to point out,
this is what I ended up
using to get the specific type
of thumbnails that we saw when
we were playing back videos.
It's making use of a few
things like absolute
positioning and clipping
the video.
For those who've played around
in the YouTube API before, you
probably know that we still
return thumbnails that are in
a 4 to 3 aspect ratio, while
most videos are in a 16 to 9
aspect ratio.
This is slightly annoying.
But it's not really something
that we could go back and
change all the thumbnails for
all the existing 4 to 3 videos
out there and not break
things too much.
So it's kind of a legacy
constraint that you could take
advantage of CSS to
fix on your end.
If you know that most of your
videos are going to 16 to 9
anyway you can use this clip
property over here to cut out
the top and bottom letter box
that would normally appear on
your thumbnail and just show
the actual video content.
So that's kind of useful for any
folks out there who've run
into similar things and want
to make use of that type of
CSS for displaying
your thumbnails.
The other thing I wanted to talk
about was just an example
of how we're doing the
CORS for talking
to the YouTube API.
And there's a whole bunch
of code over here.
Unfortunately, I feel a little
guilty because I have a module
called utils.js, and
it's 14 kilobytes.
And it's much bigger than
anything else in the code.
And that's always a sign that
you're in a little bit of
trouble, when you have this one
big function that does a
lot of things.
So I probably should refactor
this a bit.
Apologies that I have not.
But I don't want that to stop
me from actually showing off
some of the code.
And what this is going
to do is define
something called get Feed.
And this something that's really
common for YouTube API
developers out there.
You want to write some
JavaScript code that will
access a feed of videos.
And you want to get
all the videos.
Those of you familiar with the
YouTube data API know that we
only return videos in a certain
maximum number of
items per page, we call it.
So by default, you only get
back 25 videos at once.
You could use a URL parameter,
say I want to receive 50
videos back.
But if you're going through the
uploads feed of a given
user and that user happens to
have hundreds of videos,
you're not going to get all
those videos back through a
single API call.
And this is intentional.
It's something that developers
kind of have to work around
and make multiple API calls if
they want to retrieve all the
data at once.
And that could be a
little cumbersome.
So I wanted to share
how I'm doing that.
And that's in this Get Feed
function over here.
So Get Feed takes the kind of
infamous options object that
just has a bunch of different
properties that
are set over here.
And I tried to make it as
generic as possible.
So I will take in a maximum
number of results.
If you want to say, hey, I only
want to get 200 videos,
even if there are more than
200 videos in a feed, I'm
making use of getting back the
videos in JSON format, getting
back the response speed in
JSON format, just because
that's obviously much, much
easier to parse from
JavaScript than a default
XML format.
And I'm also making use of local
storage caching in this
particular case.
So I check to see whether
there's already an instance of
that particular feed cached
in local storage
in the user's browser.
And if there is and it hasn't
expired, I think I have a
fairly short expiration time set
for those, then I'll just
return that cache version.
And this is great.
For instance, I'm using the
rejected video playlist quite
a bit in the code and not having
to fetch that unless I
know it's changed it's great.
It just means that there are
that many fewer API calls, and
much more responsive
user interface.
So that's just handling some
of the options over here.
And the actual meat of things,
the jQuery AJAX call
is right over here.
And this is what's going to
request the YouTube API feed.
And I'm taking a look at
the response over here.
I'm seeing whether
there actually is
any data being returned.
If there is not any data being
returned, then I could just
call the callback right away
and pass in results.
That means I'm at the
end of the feed.
But if there is some data, then
I'm going to use this
merge method in jQuery to kind
of concatenate the new data
that I just got back from my
most recent API call with any
collected data that I
may have gotten from
previous API calls.
And I'm going to check to see
whether I want to make it
request for the next
page of results.
And assuming I do, I call
get feed recursively.
And I pass in some new options,
basically just
incrementing the start index.
So you get the next page
worth of results
And finally, regardless, I'll
invoke this callback and pass
in results.
So I'm not going to say this
is necessarily the best
JavaScript code in the world.
But it works.
And it's kind of an efficient
way of getting the entire feed
from JavaScript using CORS.
So feel free to borrow that
for your own purposes if
that's something you think
you might want to do.
So we're running a little bit
longer than I was hoping.
But there was a lot
to talk about.
I want to spend maybe a minute
or two just talking about some
future enhancements for
YouTube Direct Lite.
Let folks know where the
platform might be going.
Everybody out there is kind of
interested in the new YouTube
data API 3.0 that is currently
unreleased, but should be
released as soon as it's
ready, more or less.
So we are really eager to move
to using the YouTube API v3 in
YouTube Direct Lite.
It actually offers
some advantages.
That basically, I spend a lot
of time talking about how
great CORS is.
And it is great.
But we kind of have to deal with
the fact that Internet
Explorer 9, and 8, and 7 don't
support CORS natively.
And that's a little
bit of a bummer.
Because there's obviously lots
of folks using that.
With the YouTube API Version
3, there's actually a
different method of
communicating with our API
servers via JavaScript that
doesn't require using CORS.
And it doesn't required JSONP.
It allows for a fully
authenticated
right access to API.
It's really nifty.
So I'm kind of eager to take
advantage of that and also
make YouTube Direct Lite one of
the flagship applications
that are using Version
3 of the API.
So looking forward to
upgrade to that.
Those of you who end up looking
through the code will
kind of note that I have this
weird kind of routing scheme
set up for URLs.
Everything's based on URL
fragments for redirecting to
different pages.
And I have some
modules set up for RequireJS.
But I'm not really using
one of the kind of--
I don't know that there's any
standard MVC framework for
JavaScript right now.
Because it seems like there's
three or four kind of
competing ones.
And they're all popular
for their own reasons.
So I really probably should
migrate the code to use one of
those and make things a little
bit more, I guess, industry
standard and less just me
hacking together a solution
that probably already exists
in a more elegant way.
So that's another thing I'm
looking at for the future.
And finally, just
internationalization.
Unfortunately, I didn't have
time to add in an easy fashion
to YouTube Direct Lite
for this release.
Ideally, all the strings in
the interface would be
specified in some
external file.
Or it should be really easy to
swap in new files that have
many different translations for
different languages and
use the browser to type what
the current language is and
display the appropriate
strings to
users based on that.
That's a really important thing
that I did not have time
to do, but I would like
to do in the future.
JEREMY: Hey, Jeff.
Another one that I think
is pretty neat
is the mobile stuff.
You'd mentioned that you were
thinking about when v3 comes
out, kind of porting over what
was done with YouTube Direct
for the Android and iOS.
Would you mind talking
about that?
Because I know I have some
people that are very
interested in that.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
So YouTube Direct had a
corresponding iOS and Android
application that we wrote that
allowed folks to basically
look at all the available--
I guess we were calling them
assignments in YouTube Direct.
But basically it's different
playlists that are available
to submit to.
Choose the playlist and then
choose a video that's either
local on the storage of your
phone or record a new video
using the built-in camera on
your phone and then submit
that video for consideration
in a given playlist.
And that's not something that
we have ported to work with
YouTube Direct Lite
backends yet.
Conceptually, it's not
very difficult.
I mean, really, all we need to
do is add the perfect keyword
to each video when it gets
submitted and kind of change
the UI around a little bit to
take into account the fact
that we're reading the playlist
from a slightly
different source.
But I think one of
the points--
the code for both of those
are a little bit old.
So they built on Version
2 of the API.
We're really excited
about Version 3.
And one of the reasons is
because there's a really great
Android library that talks to
Version 3 of the API, along
with other Google APIs.
And it would really make sense
to kind of hold off on
updating the code for those
applications until we could
rewrite them for Version 3.
So that's kind of the long-term
plan for those
applications.
It's a really exciting
use case.
And we do want to support
local submissions.
JEREMY: Cool.
Did you guys want to jump into
questions really quickly?
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JEREMY: All right.
So we had a couple.
I think they're mainly actually
for YouTube Direct.
So I don't know--
well, I'll read them off.
And we can kind of discuss
them a little bit.
The first one was kind of asking
to run through step by
step using Eclipse and
running the software.
But that's obviously
for YouTube Direct.
JEFF POSNICK: Right.
And that's a common--
JEREMY: We do have some great
tutorials on that.
But again, we're kind of
focusing on YouTube Direct
Lite here, where you don't
have to do that.
It's a lot easier.
JEFF POSNICK: Sorry, and I just
want to point out that's
completely understandable.
The fact that folks needed to
use Eclipse to deploy YouTube
Direct is a real big barrier.
And I'm sorry about that.
We actually do have
an AND script that
you could also use.
But using AND for folks who
don't know how to use Eclipse
is kind of like saying, OK,
well, maybe you're not going
to mountain climb, but you
should go snorkel instead.
I mean, both are very
difficult to do.
So I would really suggest, if
you're getting stuck on
YouTube Direct deployment, try
YouTube Direct Lite instead.
It's a lot simpler to
get started with.
JEREMY: So again, this one's
a little bit focused
on the other one.
But do I have to run
NoJS for this?
If yes, please suggest
some host on this
aside from App Engine.
JEFF POSNICK: So you do not
need to run NoJS for this.
You can make use of the fact
that we are hosting kind of I
guess what we're calling the
reference implementation of
YouTube Direct Lite for
everybody to use on an App
Engine instance, which just
happens to be App Engine.
But it could be any static--
any web server that's capable of
serving out static HTML and
JavaScript and CSS.
So if you do not want to host
anything, you don't have to.
You can just point the new
iFrame source to the specific
reference implementation URL.
And that's the URL that you'll
get from the Admin Control
panel when you create
a new playlist.
So you don't have to
run anything in
particular on your end.
If you did want to host your own
version, then you can use
any standard HTTP server
to serve those files.
There's absolutely nothing
specific to the code that
would make it run on Apache and
not like [? 8, Lite, ?]
HTTP or anything like that.
It should be completely
agnostic.
So feel free to use whatever
your existing platform is,
including App Engine if you
happen to be using App Engine
for other things.
JEREMY: Great.
So we have two more,
or three more.
And this is actually a reason
you should use YouTube Direct
Lite. "In YouTube Direct flow,
I get the following error.
It's around AuthSub, the target
path prefix, even
though I authenticated my Google
domains in the panel.
Will Lite version offer easier
and less buggy authentication
mode?"
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So using the Lite version, if
you make use of the reference
implementation, then you don't
have to worry about setting up
anything having to do OAuth2.
It's already set up for you.
You just have to add that
iFrame to your page.
So in that sense, yes, it'll
be much, much easier.
To talk the specific error
that you were seeing with
YouTube Direct, I have a feeling
that it just has--
I don't want to point to user
error in this particular case,
but I have a feeling that when
entering the specific
redirection URL, the page where
you set up AuthSub,
probably something was
entered incorrectly.
And sometimes this happens when
you specify HTTP apps
instead of HTTP or vice versa.
I can't necessarily debug
exactly what's going on.
But the one thing that you do
have to set up is, if you are
running your own instance of the
YouTube Direct Lite code,
you do need to in that case
register your own OAuth2
client ID and have that
inserted into the
configuration ahead of time.
So there is a process where
using the Google API's console
and setting up OAuth2 with a new
project and putting that
into the configuration--
I think it's pretty
easy to do.
I mean, it's not the
same process as
doing the AuthSub release.
So if you found AuthSub's set up
to be confusing, maybe the
OAuth2 set up would be
a little bit easier.
And we have plenty of good
tutorials online
for how to do that.
JEREMY: Great.
And then the most important
question, "Is YouTube
Developer Relations hiring?"
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
we are hiring.
In fact, both YouTube Developer
Relations and Google
Developer Relations.
The place to look for
more information is
developers.google.com/jobs.
And you can see all the
positions that we have listed,
the types of positions.
So if you're interested,
please check out
developers.google.com/jobs,
and apply.
JEREMY: Great.
Well, Jeff, thanks so much for
putting this together.
I think it was really helpful.
And there was lots
of great answers
for some of my questions.
JEFF POSNICK: Thank you guys
for I guess taking the back
seat for a week.
And I know we're going to return
next week to a more
Mountain View focused show.
JEREMY: Great.
JEFF POSNICK: Thanks,
everybody.
JEREMY: And thanks everyone
for joining.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
Bye folks.